welcome to judge a podcast violently
high-fived over our various miss a
morning a special episode the Debbie
machine is back Debbie's heroes second
her second podcast rated by the
legendary enjoy talking about the Jenna
doing things amongst the other things
thank you for joining us today this
episode is sponsored by Credit Karma
check your credit score for free right
now trust me it is great text Jenna
Julian to eighty nine eight hundred get
the download link to their free app and
you will be right under way to checking
your credit score also brought to you by
canvas pop canvas pop is basically what
you dreamed of when you were a kid you
will be put on a giant fabulous and
looking like a movie saw on the nicest
material that you will find cameras pop
is so sure you will like it they have a
hundred sent here on TV elected it when
we find you you will get 40% off 40% off
site-wide right now canvas pop calm by
entering JJ 40th check out we will have
way more on that later thank you to my
sponsors yeah thank you sponsors thank
you to the Debbie machine that helps us
get those sponsors
yeah lobby we don't know Debbie machine
but behind the scenes is the one nailing
down all these sponsors to help us get
supported with the party yeah keep the
podcast a lot of hot guys running to see
my podcast later I mean it would still
be alive it would be alive if we didn't
have sponsors uh but it would suck a lot
more yes it does suck as much as it did
in the beginning when we had a camera
that would only focus on one of us at a
time well I mean genuinely she does an
incredible job of of keeping the system
of the podcast running cuz as you guys
know Jen and I have other things that we
have our time consumed by itself yeah
debbie has understand stepped up and now
she is podcast section cuz she helps the
podcast now she's in the podcast again
yeah because they know you're dreaming
right now though I'm exhausted by all
the hard work that I do every day but
you know what nobody knows if you work
hard if you don't tell everyone about it
everyone knows that
so to those so shoot how can anyone
possibly know there's another card
unless you just rag about it endlessly
on social media it's ready you create
it's not like you're gonna your your
hard works gonna turn into something
that people see it's not gonna be for
itself not gonna speak for itself plus
how can anyone possibly respect your
work ethic if they don't fully
understand it's pretty clear there's
going to be there's that we we made up
this pretty cool contest for canvas pop
will tell you guys about it later when
we talk about sponsors but it'll be
pretty fun so stay tuned for for you
know mid-roll the podcast will let you
know what's going down Abbi
Debbie daddy um Debbie is here because I
was Thanksgiving I hope you guys all had
one of the Thanksgiving yeah or if
you're not American I hope you got to
hang out your family at some point where
you will during whatever winter holidays
that you television hmm yep it's about
family at this point and I also hope you
didn't die going Black Friday shopping
did you guys know that for Black Friday
cards against humanity' you read about
this no cards against humanity' posted
on their website and on their social
saying for Black Friday we were offering
nothing for five dollars and over fifty
thousand dollars was made nothing they
literally checked a box that says I
understand I'm paying five dollars for
nothing in return and they made fifty
and so try the biggest roles in my world
keeper to know what they're doing do
something that money and a gun fifty
thousand dollars
they're gonna hire that one game that
not getting my god that one guy that
came to play you every game no no no
they're gonna hire that one guy that
couldn't play at work the one that wrote
all those hysterical cards I'm sorry but
the ones that are outrageously funny
came from one do one time he just showed
no no just showed up working was like
alright I got the fire right now
excellent a bit cocky yeah like
next-level a SuperSoaker phobic at peace
yeah next level Rush Limbaugh's soft
shitty body no for those of you played
they're gonna take for you wouldn't
expect there's like one car yes
that's just like yeah it's a trump card
all right uh-huh anyway yeah right it's
hilarious so what I thought we could do
because last time the debuted him on the
podcast true right
last time the Debbie machine was here we
played internet like trivia with you
yeah yeah and we had you answer a bunch
of in here you did really really well
then it was maybe off the pot yeah and
the puff so I mean you're you're pretty
involved with Twitter and you know
people know that you're my mom and
you're you know you're on the internet a
fair amount so what I thought would be
pretty interesting and I looked for a
little bit and was like I we could do a
whole podcast with these as I just asked
on the our podcast Twitter account for
people to ask you some questions so we
just answer those people just want to
get to know you
yeah yeah try not to fall asleep oh my
god oh my oh I'm the mom tag and I'm she
said she was to ask me a question then I
would answer and she'd go wait okay to
be fair though like we had never shot a
video together so I didn't think you
knew how like fast like you know when
you're making video content a lot of
times you try and make it like as short
as possible because I'm gonna go and sit
down and edit it you have like 12
[ __ ] hours of footage to look at so
some of the questions you're kind of
just like talking and talking and Talia
and I just sat there I'm like mom it's
[ __ ] Thanksgiving we're shooting that
we have like three hours of footage
right now if you don't answer this
[ __ ] question we're never gonna eat
dinner alright anyways that um would you
like to go on with the questions for
people on Twitter no happy oh okay okay
I'm gonna do whatever you know yeah yeah
I'm gonna sing or no no I think she
needs to be asked the questions yes we
need dance
I was kidding I'm kidding alright she's
lit okay I'm lit but um okay here's a
very Twitter question from Molly 108
days yomo ah ask her her thoughts on 21
pilots
mmm I thought there were 22 oh okay
you know
there's your answer you're a band or a
band mom I know they're a band I don't
know anything about them you firing just
say their lip because they are they lit
okay what's your favorite song hold on
hold on Tyler or Josh no just come on
pick one
Lancers higher or Josh no answers now
she's right because remember they took a
poll in City
she knows she's she's t.o.p she's click
daddy machine what's your favorite song
right now is it an old song is a new
song hmm I don't know
but that's hard cuz I you know I'm not
really like dude listen to me well she
does have a lot of original songs that
she sings all the time and I was after
are these covers are these originals and
they're original she's coming up with
songs like all of them in musical
instruments and it was my turn right
remember we were just playing the forks
a little while ago yeah so what's my
favorite song uh you know um I don't
know hey Debbie pick on we got a lot of
questions no I like the pressure I don't
know I got you can do it pressure is
that an old song which one of your
favorite old songs well I'm a big jimmy
hendrix fan oh yeah I'm very excited cuz
I just I forgot these tickets to it's a
tour and um what's going I think just
east coast use it as hologram okay yeah
it's not a solid camera so to me Ziggy
Marley is that right now Dweezil Zappa
oh boy that's cool
yes anyway so anytime any Jimi Hendrix
song what's your favorite is it all
along the watchtower what's your
favorite Jimi Hendrix song there's one
one called Barry is decisive for the six
turns out to be 9 ok ok good good to
know for the record all right uh what
was the most trouble Jenna cost you as a
teenager Oh F give me a break right you
have the entire podcast so go as long as
where does one begin where does one
begin I mean you can't even begin to
know you know she's so she getting a
phone call but let me answer it is my
favorite thing to do in class I really
we talked about this before though
teaching her to drive was just was not
pretty it was just like a most awful
thing a terrible and I really wanted
someone else a teacher but no one would
so I was stuck and then we finally got
her lessons with them you know somebody
from the outside
I would say no I went to drivers and I
saw was it happened but you also went to
driving school I did yes when it was
Holly Morgan my senior something like
that yeah
yeah oh you had you had to because no no
I couldn't reach you and you've never
there was no teaching you did you did
you hear that what you just said I
couldn't teach you yeah you were
unteachable no this is not my inability
to learn it was her inability to teach
yeah I read the whole time outside
perspective it's probably a combination
yeah I didn't say that I could have I
mean why I ever thought I could was
beyond me to go I said hi I guess it yes
I did we see outside was literally good
did Julian let me tell you what would
happen I would start driving and she
would scream at me to stop that's what
would happen but that's what every child
feels like when their parents and I
alter see when they're learning promise
you I'll Drive the car around the block
and by the time we got to the stop sign
at the end of the street she was already
screaming at me my dad still grabs this
thing was in the hotel that was given
just well like still today he said
killed today I you know extent today if
I'm driving which I don't know I'd ever
be driving my dad's you know in the past
mercy he's always driving around driving
I'm car bet he's always like thinking
could I tell a different jealous story
than that yes oh so Jenna has had a
unique style as a teenager and it it
went from being highly sophisticated to
wearing one of the most sophisticated
prom dresses of all the young ladies at
your prom what to you know having I had
a sophisticated style wait so yes can we
just like a hold on I just want I have
so many questions so it's sophisticated
in like in other kids weren't doing she
was like taking risks and doing
different things it's not like we had a
lot of money well just the what the
dress I'm thinking about is that pink
sequin no I know but okay let's hear
about the pink seeking choose no
guidance right well so you know she's a
very nice figure and so she so she would
what you want to go not not as a senior
but when she was younger
junior George the junior years you know
she wanted she had a particular dress in
mind it's a we I think we went to
Toronto did we uh New York because aunt
Diane was with New York but we went with
you and I did go to Toronto another time
because we got those we saw it's got a
chore
anyway so we went and so you know we
looked at so many stores we were in New
York you ate so many sores and then but
she knew exactly what she wanted and in
this pink dress I remember the other
mothers were saying to me like wow yeah
that's quite the dress no it wasn't you
know it had like regular straps it was
just a long fitted pink sequined dress
it wasn't like you know revealing or
anything but it was just very so there
was that part of the wardrobe very
sophisticated all the way down to a pair
of shoes a pair of sneakers where there
was nothing in the front yeah my sneaker
sandals the sneaker sandals which before
sneaker sandals even existed you still
have that was like oh no I do that and
so people so when she would go she would
wear them and people would say oh those
poor more kids I can't even afford shoes
well we'd go get it and then I shopped a
problem in this like ball gown one hand
ma-fuckers right I can't afford she saw
her mas Negro sales but then everybody
remember when you were younger you
started wearing two different colored
socks and in the beginning people were
like you should go in she's wearing
socks you know what's wrong with her
well then we know she was a trend setter
or not exactly that everyone all the
kids in the school were like wearing two
different colored socks so it was like a
cool thing so you do have good dissing
dress this grade but it's the range yeah
yeah she's versatile she's not just one
thing right other huh but also you would
say to me oh if I could just sew this I
have I know exactly what I want I could
just make that then I could do it I know
I have the biggest cheers that you made
it says Halloween costumes those weren't
credit ya know I've sewed myself dresses
and stuff they're not hard to make but
the reason for that just live drama that
I was so stuck on this dress is because
I already drew it out and I knew that
want it and so that was the problem so
if I think about it too much they know
what I want then I you see me at the
mall and I'm like I'm looking for X and
then it doesn't exist so then I'll just
wear black leggings and black tank top
jacket so we wanted to Rallo and that's
where you found your moon boots
oh yeah and yeah we looked we were we
went to nine million stores and then
we're walking by this boutique and she
goes oh my God look at those in the
window no you're actually in Boston
Oh embossed it whatever anyway
you're walking by and you say oh look at
those and I'm like wow those are kind of
weird but okay you know you will it was
you know what you like them moon boots
because I know that now there are a
company called moon boots or whatever
that make the same winter boots that
look they ripped off that style but when
we saw them before I got them they
didn't exist as a boot as like a winter
boot because you know if you live in
Rochester you need an actual functional
boot and these were very they just look
like you're going to space and the
functionality of them wasn't a hundred
percent welcome back to the Future right
and so I wore them I don't have them
anymore I got rid of them when I moved
to Los Angeles because he can't pack
boots and [ __ ] you're like alright I got
to give this up but I had them until it
was 25 right so it's not just that she
likes them it's that she knows what she
wants you know what you want and you are
clear and then you get it you know yeah
so that's that's a very I think that's a
very unusual thing to have such a clear
point of view what what you actually
like she's always been yeah right oh I
got relentlessly made fun of for those
boots and socks and whatever the hell
but like sneaker sandals I remember cuz
I wore those through college I got them
in seventh grade and I wore them through
college which is why they had no feet
but I would like wear them to parties
and [ __ ] when like people would be like
are you alright dude like I remember my
friend Ashley told me her friend was
driving by and saw me walking school my
sneaker sandals they were like [ __ ] oh
right like does she need shoes like nah
dude those are her shoes I don't know
what to tell you well at least it's
functional for the freezing-cold when
you don't have folks I know my socks
would get soaking wet and I didn't care
understand that I don't either I can't I
don't I can't explain myself to you
there isn't explaining megabill truth
the only reason I stopped wearing them
those because that softball season I
wound up getting like serious injuries
and my feet and legs because I wasn't
having any arch support in the room
right and so it really did end up
messing up my feet a little yeah right
so if you can get stuff to answer that's
extremely long-winded way of saying you
know look at you know that the hardest
things was or because you were very
clear and I just want to make sure you
were safe so I don't you know that's the
reconciling of those two things is is
you know the challenge of being you know
a very strong
and apparent is you know what you were
saying the other day you know give this
child food clothing shelter and love and
get the hell out of their way
yeah I was so clear that that's you know
what my job was with you just you know
make sure I provide it for you and then
get the hell out anyway this was really
a great way to raise a kid because then
your kid is very autonomous and they
make all of their own decisions and then
they sit with all their own consequences
yeah you know yeah but you know I
couldn't a hundred percent do that
because you're kidding yeah liability
and you know you should want to cut like
you can excite can't make your own
decisions that I want I'm gonna go
follow around my favorite band on tour
and drop out of school you're like that
you better not wasn't like - right
well your argument to me was always well
look I didn't do anything I I don't do
anything bad right I don't do anything
wrong
I don't worry white perfect why are they
she's bad stuff right I mean she didn't
do drugs of ChaCha
I never want me probably drank by me
Mort Lorenz did [ __ ] up [ __ ] but I
wouldn't do anything dad ever cuz I was
terrified of the wrath of Debbie the
Debbie Machine wrath is not one mortals
can take mm-hmm no because I was like I
played too many sports and did too much
stuff to like be able to get away with
[ __ ] like even through college yeah
we're music yeah when you plays here in
college I can't just go do yeah but I
mean that goes that goes for like your
whole life anytime you have too much
free time you're getting in the [ __ ]
you shouldn't I didn't do yeah all right
what's what's the next question what do
we got next
um Oh God ask her when her mixtape is
dropping it's a question when is it
Devon so I'm not sure how to do it I
need a produce you a producer I am I'm
dr. J I could I could be your producer I
got beets
I got beets I got a beet ready in the
computer we actually have these I just
have a headphone I do I sit there and
make them real quick and then I'm like
all right done
yeah you have like a secret gift that
nobody really like understands that you
can just sit down and like in an hour
have whole beat yeah the one I made
recently actually you always do you know
but you I usually I'm doing them on like
a
time crunch though so they're not as
good as it could be but the other day I
was like are I'm gonna make it [ __ ]
fire right now
yeah it's pretty dope so Jones took
piano lessons when she was little last
year and so she went they went to a
classical not trained classically
trained piano teacher right not
something else and so they were so she
would fund the very beginning she could
listen to a song and then come home and
play got it like play it there on there
not not classical back you learn to play
by ear yeah um and people in my part her
poor brother was like she can't do it
really oh my God he's completely
tone-deaf God loved him I just remember
okay so Devon my brother is like six
foot five those those of you listeners
know that stuff but like he's he grew in
a foot all of a sudden and was very
uncoordinated for a time when he was a
teenager and I remember like you know
long was struggling initially with like
he struggled with everything like he
struggled in school he struggled like
physically struggled like in every way
possible and he really worked and now
you know he's great a lot of things but
for everybody was a teenager he was like
really upset about certain things cuz I
remember one time I was like looking
into his gym class cuz we were like in
the same school and he's just over there
like struggle busing I remember he
failed the Damascus unit because all he
could do is log roll like literally the
only thing he could physically do is
just listen stupid well he didn't know
what to do with all that right exactly
at like you know you get your physical
fitness test he could only do like 12
jump ropes in like a minute like his
just like his rope was too short he
could just like step over it he's he's
so upset like I just remember him being
so angry in gym class he's gonna do [ __ ]
but I did not know that he was also
upset that he couldn't play piano or
sing completely toms not easy to be
Jenna's sibling not a true high sex toy
story 20 no so I always figured Hughes
better at everything yes except for
anything physical so I was like Tiffany
sure but by high school he was fine
whatever
it is how
a deal to have a gazillion Twitter
children oh that's really fun it is for
you but you are like great and
interacting that's what I love what like
my favorite part of my feed most the
time is like Debbie quoting other
people's questions and giving the best
responses like all the time even at 4
a.m. on the East Coast
well you know I always do my thing I
wake up in the middle of that because I
get to stay up all night you know then
when you have kids you end up changing
your time because you have to do what
the kids do now I kind of have gone back
to it but I don't you know usually I'm
taking you home now
right and then I wake up like really
enjoy I used to do like what you guys do
which is I used to stay up and my normal
self would stay up until 2:00 or 3:00 in
the morning you know or even later and
then sleep until 10:00 or 11:00 or
whatever it is then you have then you
have children you get a job that's right
I can't do that anymore so I haven't
quite gone back to it but when I wake up
and have two hours in the middle of the
night when I'm awake I'm not upset it
the most part you work from home so
you're able to like not have to wait and
I just refer to I would wake up and read
a book if I didn't have Twitter but I
really like it because I feel like no
it's also having fun because it lines up
with us perfect like right when it's
like midnight 1:00 a.m. for us that's
what Twitter time for Debbie starting
and we're just like what she got going
on here all right uh name three things
that are lit I've been to st. Assam's
from Kaitlin wild Catelynn name why name
three things that are lit all three of
us at this table are only lit confirmed
with um Rose no no I'm not arguing with
that
marzia marbles wants to know if you have
any funny airport stories um Airport not
so much but airplane kind of a kind of a
I don't stop me why it's boring but
anyway I had a chance to sit next to
somebody they were Alfa Nader people
know who real oh yeah but you said it's
a Ralph Nader on a plane yeah so I was a
long long time ago I was you know
probably in my 20s
like and so I'm at the Rochester Airport
he had been speaking someplace so he's
standing there and you can tell you can
see him he's huge he's like six five
yeah it's four he's a big guy so he says
all that I won't say the airlines it
doesn't matter the people behind the
counter like more and more people are
coming out from behind the counter that
I see him I'm like oh you know Ralph
Nader and you could hear him saying look
these people have rights and you've over
booked this plane and the people there's
like ten people design a little shower
right people have flights and you stay
in the behind the name and they're like
okay well we'll figure it out so the
lady comes at you know time passed he
gets on the plane lady comes out and
says who wants a seat next to Ralph
Nader me so I go on the plane kind of
sitting next to him he's got this big
pile of books you know in his lap like
he's got to read on the plane
what the hell and pile of books on his
lap I mean because you know yes let's
eat that pocket does he's reading or
whatever I mean it was list hi anyway so
he said so I said I'm sorry I don't mean
to bother you but you expunged it all
I'm a big fan and thank you for your
hard work and I'll leave you alone he
goes oh no I said I'd love to talk to
people so you know head of having a
little conversation with them and it
turns out that sitting he I was sitting
in the window and he was sitting here
there was a guy here and then his is
with a little boy they were clearly his
son and I turned out I knew who this was
and I well I won't say who it is but I'm
gonna get myself into trouble although
catch our job so i'll turns out that he
was an attorney at codec and I worked at
coding right and so this guy I have
interacted with this guy a lot but I was
there in my jeans and my little you know
looking a little whatever I was looking
so this guy in a million years never
would have known that it was me ah so he
said to Ralph Nader that guy over there
is an attorney for Kovac he calls me
it's great
what's his name I seem to know dator
turns to him and says um are you this is
it yeah
and he goes what How Do You Know Who I
am because I read I read minds
Oh mom are you making this story yeah no
you got it off e in the god the guy goes
is it attorneys like so he said no wait
you do this and this is right because I
was telling about
right man all right because this guy
doesn't you know I'm sitting over there
this guy it never occurs to this guy
because of who I am I'm some girl right
oh my god I never even thinks maybe I'm
feeding him did you like that guy work
or was he kind of like he wasn't a jerk
he was a jerk yeah okay well you know
you call that hold on you don't call
that call it karma exactly similar to
our sponsor this week Credit Karma
right now text Joe Julian eight nine
eight hundred get the pretty app okay
not only you get your perfectly accurate
credit score it's one of the most
accurate you get out there there's a lot
of ways to get your credit score yeah
you like that one that's good then I get
your credit score on the app it's for
free there's they don't ask any there's
no strings attached
I'd use it it's an amazing service not
only do your credit score but once you
have the Apple it's your you know logged
in with them you have options to get
monitoring alerts different different
notifications for when your credit score
changes or when you're doing something
that could both improve and hurt the
credit score this is the way to keep an
eye on your credit score like like an
adult should so Credit Karma check them
out by texting our names Jenna Julianne
289 800 you get the free app and you
guys won't be disappointed it is a great
app it is a great way considering
there's so many crap ways to get your
credit score now that was enough they
don't want anything they want you to
have your accurate credit score check
them out all right also our second
sponsor campus pop you guys know about
that I told you about them the coolest
looking campus is like great material
crystal-clear pictures you send them
whatever pics you want they will blow it
up putting on a beautiful canvas and
send it to you 40% off by entering JJ 40
at checkout site-wide on canvas pops on
percent free things okay so that's
that's the first part the second part is
we got something sent to us from them
because they were like hey you know
we're gonna sponsor you guys let's send
you something so just the way the
podcast sometimes goes we sent them
pictures of me and Jenna those pictures
didn't they weren't high rent and
where's my res they were from my phone
yeah so they were just like hey these
pictures need to be high-res so that's
electric time I had a great we have your
dog I mean I school out us I stink
to send the right away your stressors
before Tokyo I just sent the wrong
pictures anyway they were like we have
to send these so they sent ones of Jena
to giant pictures yeah here's one of
them okay it's awesome
no this is it right here Carmen is we
held up Carmen asked my status it's
literally like my stone is like
beautiful no it's amazing uh so we're
not gonna keep this okay cuz that's
weird but what we're going to do is we
are going directly on my ceiling can i
one on my side yeah we have to so what
we're gonna do else is an earthquake
though to you guys if you don't want to
buy your own gift spot but you want the
opportunity to enter a contest or
whatever you want to call it to win that
one or the other one there are two that
you can win we will sign them for you
all you got to do is go follow campus
pop on twitter so CA and VA s pop on
Twitter go follow them right now okay
and in the next couple of days we're
going to look through their new
followers and select a winner two
winners actually design them and get
your address and send to you you could
be the proud new owner of a giant and
the marvelous canvas pop with Kermit
I think Kermit and mumbles on the other
one they're very very beautiful and not
only like you know even if you don't win
these they are such high-quality pieces
of art it is it's like they're turning
your pictures into a beautiful piece of
art so I've had a great picture of like
you and your family be a really cool
thing to have
yes absolutely yet and in their brain
with customer service
it's called canna spot cuz that's canvas
right yeah a great customer service if
you don't like it they will literally
print an entire thing for you and then
get it back and then give you our money
like it's great great cool so follow
canvas pop on Twitter in the next couple
of days we'll pick winners and those
winners will get some copies of those
I'll also sign it even though I'm not on
it
whatever we'll send it to you for free
the rest of you 40% off just yeah just
think about that because that's not
going to be for me now 40% off site-wide
thank you cans pop to a sponsors use
products coach JJ thank you guys what
are you and anyways back to this you and
Ralph Nader look rolling an Xcode
so he never found out it was you that
was due he never found out it was me but
the one other interesting thing about
that was the little boy had a had a
Rubik's Cube this was a long time ago
and so major says to me what what's he
got over there it says that's a Rubik's
Cube because I never saw that before
yeah so that means that he alternatively
has a very funny sense of humor but also
is a little bit detached from regular
life he's funny enough to try a stranger
but he doesn't know what a Rubik's Cube
yeah right right was an interesting
thing um mmm
so uh you know it was only a flight we
were flying from Rochester to DC it was
a direct flight so the whole time the
guy you could see the guy like looking
over at him like an animator would look
over go read minds right I know you and
now this guy you can see the wheels
turning like this guy's goes can you
really read my mind
he's awesome all the bad things I've
done and Ralph Nader really you know
give me some payment so we get off the
plane and I said oh would you like a
ride and my sister was coming to pick me
up in her very you said this to Ralph
Nader right would you like a ride
because he seemed kind of rumpled huh
you know like kind of I don't know like
I haven't got a lot of money I don't
know I just seen I don't know why I said
it just to be big just to be nice and he
said sure I'll take a ride and but
remember he's the seatbelt guy right so
now I'm thinking it's got this 3,000
year old Volkswagen Beetle that she
pulls up in and I said oh and she was in
television so she was used to celebrity
so it wasn't really yeah and like your
families you know and um so I said oh I
told Ralph later we go because you did
yeah we I don't have any seat belts in
my car what are we gonna do she don't
have any seat belts in her car well she
did but you didn't back back then you
know they were like buried you didn't
wear one every day like me well I
remember when we were a kid we would get
in every cab before she allowed the cab
to move she'd be like you buckle your
seat belt well you're sitting on it like
Devin's sitting on the other half
there's a scoop scuse me sir you cannot
move this car until we buckle our
seatbelts and here she is picking up
Ralph Nader with no seatbelts
so anyway he managed to uh I'm in the
backseat like Oh what did I do and he
manages to find the seat belt and manage
to pram himself into this little
Volkswagen Beetle
and we gave him a ride to the witch dear
Connecticut Avenue near I think Dupont
Circle but anyway um guys my job on
Easter know dad but he will drop you off
at your house cuz oh no don't know it
was like he was trying to because people
must avoid a lot of New Year is oh no
what she was just rying to be nice and I
don't think you might know but you don't
want people to know where you right
right so anyway that's the relative I'll
never forget dick I never forget that
guys I'm the remember his name - Charlie
you guys have a great conversation Joe
just say I'll roll you teams rolled with
it right the other thing you see said he
loves when he travels places he loves to
like drive by he sees a buyer right and
he goes isn't Rosie's bar around here
someplace and I went when the car goes
what how you been - Rosie's bar oh yeah
he's right around here somewhere he
never been there right but he just saw
it just looks of like they're all people
I had no idea that's so funny what a
troll I love that anyway that's there I
love finding out that people I had no
idea where trolls are trolls I would
likely continue to run for president
regardless of anything four years four
years did not give a [ __ ]
well it takes votes away from a lot of
people no matter what way you come your
with you just always giving people an
option like [ __ ] everybody I'm not gonna
win I'm just gonna [ __ ] run yeah oh
there's a respect for sure right it was
a sad day when I was like where's Ralph
yeah
is he wrong in or Rob were you out yeah
you have were you bad are you out you
trolling on their plane right now is
that she's trolling somebody someplace
that we can confirm yeah um pastel Mel
wants to know mac and cheese your
grilled cheese grilled yeah grill the
ships good choice we were just talking
about these are fun with a girl cheese
sandwich and then wrapped wrapped around
vacation well not well like wrapped one
way and then wrap the other way in bacon
and when they cut into it oh man I mean
you know like that story is Josh
shocking yeah nobody from having
formerly from Epic Meal Time he
literally his entire snapchat and
everything he does now
like it makes me hungry all like he
comes up with the craziest things he
made my name pizza but the crust was
fried cheese
there was no crust there was literally
just fried cheese and that was the
bottom of pizza
um Sonja Hawks you know song yeah she
wants to know a three-part question
that's advice you've ever received one
book you think everyone should read and
why we don't call moustaches mouth brows
Wow that third question okay now we have
to start with number three because
that's the best one hey mouth bro mmm um
moustache mouth bro I mean it should be
called a man should be called oh she is
correct she's perfect or a mouth - look
not that bro I like brow betel bro
eyebrow mouth bro eyebrow lip bribe row
lip brow hi stache not breath right - I
mean I was just thinking about this
thing so they have childhood and
adulthood but in the middle they call it
adolescence not teenagehood and why is
that
oh because teenage would often tell me
they were like what rolls off the tongue
well that's baby that's like mustache
and I got round I mean opera I'm just
like English word historian but like
Syria is like adult less and the essence
of it the essence of being less than an
adult man a communal adult the master's
degree in psychology
okay oh man never climbed in masters in
English okay what book you think
everyone should read though yeah well
[ __ ] that stuff um what's a good book I
you know what I don't know why this is
coming to my mind I'm just gonna say it
cos who knows there's a book called zen
and the art of motorcycle maintenance by
a guy named Robert Pierce aghh it's a
little bit hard to get through
um but it's a book I very much heard it
here y'all great read oh then on the art
zen and the rDNA article motor sunette
at all none okay that's probably not
there's a wonderful book called a
curious instant the Curious Incident of
a dog and then I about the dog and the
knight or something like that by Mark
Hayden another wonderful book that I
read motorcycle maintenance
many years ago I've read the mark Aidan
book in recent times so I guess it
depends on what you want to do and why
you're doing it
with all of that best advice she's ever
received best advice yeah it's the best
advice but I would say you know um you
don't trust myself hmm who told you that
uh well I probably told myself I don't
really not advice hey hey hey is this a
good time she's giving advice it passed
down I appreciate it I mean I guess
maybe somebody did say that to me and I
didn't know I don't mean I don't
remember exactly what was but it's
probably the most important thing it's
probably the thing I always told you
guys as kids it's what I tell people and
you know when they say oh I feel feel
it's like you can do this yes it's good
I tell new parents look nobody knows
that baby like you know that baby you
can trust yourself yeah believe in you
you just it's okay you're gonna make
mistakes it's okay we all make this
mistakes that's that's not the problem
but I just feel like people doubt
themselves so much and they wait for
someone else on the outside to validate
them like okay I'm not going to try this
unless somebody says it's okay to do and
it goes like across everything like what
you wear what you say what you think and
you have to just believe in yourself
well I mean it's it's something that
like you when you see someone who you
feel strongly about like you know you
see someone for the first time and you
really like them
and you really appreciate their presence
and you like how they carry themselves
you know 90% of like I found of that is
like what they believe in themselves
like their confidence their ability to
trust their own decisions and that comes
off so strong like you meet someone
you're like oh that guy whether or not
he's right like he knows what he's doing
you know you trust him so it's a skill
to be able I'm traveling to your own
intuition and just do what you think is
right because that you can learn how to
turn it on and off and use it you know
when you want to and to your advantage
when you know how to trust yourself but
it comes from years and years and years
of not knowing if you should and just
trying it anyway absolutely
you know right I see young people you
know they like to hear them or whatever
read your emails and they're saying this
and that and how much you've helped them
everything it's you know that's what I
like I don't respond to them because we
don't but it's just you know mostly it's
just you know I just wish that they
would just say okay I'm okay I'm okay
and I'm going to figure this out and I'm
going to trust myself that I'm going to
I'm going to do it whether somebody else
tells me that or not
well you're understanding that there's a
period in everyone's life where
everything is crazy you don't believe
anything and everything is the end of
the world and people go through that and
like when they're like what do I do
there's like it's going to get better
you know trust yourself you know you're
going to come out the other end looking
back on this being like wow I really
wasn't that big of a deal yeah or it was
that big of a deal and I learned what I
needed to learn from it I know I'm
better for know I'm better for yeah yeah
all right Roxy eternal Roxy bro on
Twitter wants to know was the funniest
thing that has happened Mulligan and
dunes up mm oh my god oh yeah oh do you
think the yeah yeah
when we taught you how to whip the
Debbie whip that's pretty funny no wait
there's gotta be more let's hear what
else is funny from you I just you know
you can't really imagine what it's like
to be here except that I'm used to it so
I don't know what anybody else would
think it was like when you're here but
there's all kinds of that you go to
places there's like planets inside the
house various planets that you can visit
when you're here then there's languages
that are spoken that you don't know what
that language is and that's very
accurate in terms then there's you know
there's a world so Planet languages and
world inside the house they're not in
any specific room they seem to float or
bomb the places but they were calling
each other you call each other otter but
now it's current that's morph a little
bit into some other kind of language
October yeah that's a different language
that's good right so that's new since
the last time I was here and so that you
know so then you have to kind of catch
up on what the language is or sure but
that's part of that that to me that's
part of the most fun and the most
interesting part and just laughing out
loud because you never know what planet
or what language is gonna emerge or what
new dance or if you get that's true
that's that's pretty accurate
description of what it's like here what
is it like to be you and to be you know
is that that's how it was your house
like that when you were growing out
there I wanted it to me it was rained in
a lot cuz I was a kid trying to run wild
yeah but you know like yeah I got well
there's a lot of kids growing up in my
house yeah so there was always I like to
plan it analogy like there's different
planets within the
house like different attitudes different
vibes and then just you go to this room
and it's like whoa this kids running off
the wall and then Julian just punched
his brother and I was in timeout but
he's yelling at him and then the zone
room my mom's paintings it's like wait
what is on fire exactly yeah yeah it was
absolute chaos right yeah but did you
have those you probably had those
languages yeah yeah everything's
morphing all the time because there's my
brother and I had a secret language so
we could talk in front of our mom and
not have her note but wheeling you guys
say like two things in it and I never
developed his excuse key on Twitter
wants to know what is your favorite
slang term or trend at the moment [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh sorry [ __ ] is not a trend that's
wrong that's always been a great word
it's been delete Oh with this oh that's
my favorite I mean yesterday slide or
match end what's your favorite slit what
do you use it yeah that's good and you
know like fire you know my favorite is
fire my favorite is I'll be texting or
emailing Debbie about podcast stuff
we're we're talking business we're going
hours and hours about sponsors all the
stuff and we'll finally get to the point
where we're closing in I'm just like all
right awesome Debbie great work today
like we did it and then she doesn't
respond anything but just like live
nothing else nothing else amazing word
yeah so lit we were doing that in New
York so that's the kind of get worried
up lifting up this is a messed up
question but Gav's Magoo wants to know
do you have a favorite granddaughter
because you have five there's my three
and then my brother has Kona and Winston
which are big dogs they're big dogs
hmm you don't have to have one yeah no
because you know every one of them has
their own little joy little yeah I know
for sure you like you think about
selecting one you like but they also do
that and then the other one you're like
oh they're perfect except for that one
thing like she's she's the cutest dog in
the world but then she'll just steal all
your clothes and be naughty all the time
I just grabbed a shotgun oh yeah on our
way to happen honey and she had a big
toy as she did
yes much it she's such a game Kaley g16
wants to know your favorite holiday
tradition hmm well well hmm what holiday
and what would it be so uh holidays are
a little bit hard were a heart kind of
hard for me so now that I'm you know at
this point my life they're wonderful so
they don't carry as much having this for
me but when we were growing up my
absolute favorite thing to do was to
adopt a family at Thanksgiving at
Thanksgiving and at Christmas and then
get food and presents how that I agree
with that and then the best stuff um so
you know usually it was a family of
three or four kids and you could get
something that's awesome so we would
have a colorful actually two cards full
yeah do it with Marilyn Allen so we have
a couple cards full of food and presents
so that these people wouldn't have and
you know if I was working like when I
went to Kodak people would help
contribute so you didn't each kid just
didn't get one thing sometimes each
person would get three or four or five
things but it really did keep uh either
of us from growing up little twisted as
how the world works because before your
family before we would celebrate
Christmas with each other
you go and you give presents to an
entire family that otherwise would have
nothing and they're completely grateful
and then so then when you get your
presents in your house with your family
you're like I'm so grateful for
everything that I have so it's pretty
powerful for anybody I would have to
agree that that was one of my favorites
you are lucky to have been raised by
such a saint
yo she's like that's it's been passed
down fairly I mean she's she's a lot
like you capture the saint but yeah
mm-hmm haha it reminded me of for
Christmas you remember I forget what it
was called but it was the service where
you like you would essentially give your
whoever you bought it for a little card
that says um in whatever third-world
country don't member that either but
like I bought you a go I bought this
family oh yeah for intervention yeah
yeah yeah so we would buy those for
people and like oh you can buy a family
like
rabbit and this is what we'll give them
or you could buy them a go or yellow
whole cow go up and you'll get them
clean water whatever it is and so we
would give that to people I can't
remember who you gave it to but they
were like what the [ __ ] and I remember
us just like going back like dying
laughing cuz it's such a nice thing to
give somebody for a holiday Liam you
know what [ __ ] presents [ __ ] everything
that's not what Christmas is about
you know Hanukkah or whatever it's not
about the materialistic things we're
like we're helping another family on
each other's behalf or whatever and the
person was so like oh this isn't a but I
we didn't get the cows right yet it's
like you got a family ago they're gonna
milk it for the food and so what the
[ __ ] with a lot I remember the address
no I won't say who it was but I remember
that she does remember this and I did it
deliberately yeah like I'm not gonna buy
you anything I'm gonna buy what's right
and wrong I hate it I enjoy the two
birds if one says two birds with one go
baby
let's take a couple more questions oh my
god where do you think Jenna's love and
passions for animals came from
oh it's born in you that's not yeah you
don't teach if you believe that you know
some people don't believe in continuing
the soul reincarnation what evolution
that's okay it doesn't matter
but it's boy was born inside her she she
came out wanting to hug an animals
that's what I think I think that people
that dogs are just like you know the
same was like a person they're they're a
little energy ball that you gotta like
interact with yeah you know who knows
where they came from if it's a person in
their up what is a spirit is energy and
whatever that's what I think yeah and
most people don't know I definitely
allergic to cats and very much dogs and
so it wasn't like we could really even
have animals that same I'm a grown up
yeah so it's not like I know we had
another set was around it we did have a
lot of funny animals around but lots of
hamsters gerbils Jared okay um Danielle
heart-attack wants to know what's your
spirit animal or who or yeah I guess
that what or who is your spirit no I
guess I don't really know I'm not that
smart to be well pick an animal that you
identify with well I always like
cheetahs because you know cheetahs are
fast they're wily mmm they're the
fastest land animals they're so majestic
they're very majestic they're there but
they also chill super hard yeah they do
chill higher like a G's they're big cats
so they chill big cats that's not like
you I don't know they're just they blend
in those spots are cool yeah they're
pretty cool sounds good um here's an
interesting question M crafting Co wants
to know how do you think your life would
have changed if Jenna had been born a
boy would her personality be any
different hmm I am no idea right that's
a crazy thing to think about never
thought about you had two boys
re-announce and voyager be weird um I
mean we're friends I don't know if I'd
yeah I don't know anything that let's
pretend that you know genetics stay the
same I mean I think you would be the
same and I think you would just be like
this awesome guy that's just whatever
should be enough you're such a funny guy
Jenna I would be enough okay I mean you
know it doesn't have anything to do with
gender gender it has to do with you know
it's just the show your spirit it's your
spirit yeah your fire you know you got
fire
you know Julian has fire I'm not a very
good girl anyways I wake up and do the
best that yeah I'm nothing all right
Georgia I know right like I feel like I
got that from you though - it's like you
know all the girly things I have taken
an interest in like makeup and things as
an adult but I still it's only later for
occasions where I want to and not like
walking around looking like a [ __ ]
girl all the time I look
scrubby boy so it doesn't bother he
looks baby three looks three look last
question yeah sure last question what we
got
how old were you when you lost your
first job oh I think I was 14 um I
worked at this dry cleaners across the
street from my house and I was too young
to work but I got working papers yeah
nice to work there after school
uh-huh and I hated that place and he was
such a dork oh my god you know the
opposite of lit right so I just you know
I don't know what I did I think I mixed
up some dry cleaning on purpose so I
would get fired nice get some severance
just kidding there was no say no celery
when I worked at Express I sort of did
that too like that I hated my job like
when I worked at the edge I moved from
greeter and darwan you stand there for
literally like six hours and do nothing
but say hello and goodbye to people no
but you're saying hello to people who
walk in to express why I look like this
but then I graduated to the fitting room
where you have the who's required of us
to toss over a shirt we're trying
clothes on
so I remember they said you know uh you
know Jenna you're not tossing things
over time I'm like yeah cuz they're in a
dressing room and I figured they were
gonna try out what they wanted I hate
doing it I hate it special I hate it so
they're like alright if you don't do it
then we're gonna put you in the back I'm
like snick ma'am I'm not [ __ ] doing
it so I remember one ship they were like
Jenny you got to go to the back and just
steam some clothes I'm like perfect
so I'm [ __ ] great great I'm like I'm
not coming back my key so please Pisa I
was fired from two sales jobs to where
are you really why the shoe store they
says you wanna steal yeah right I can't
smell this people but they don't want
right one was a kids clothing park and
the other one was and they said you know
somebody buys this pair of shoes still
tell them a handbag that's how all that
long ago sold them a handbag that
matches I'm like no I'm not going to do
this feels cuz you develop this
relationship then you have to go and
turn it all bad by trying to you know
make make them buy more things I know I
could never be it just walk the handbag
over to them make sure you sure I'm
sorry I don't my mentioning as you look
at them
and we need those people in the world
yeah for some people it makes them
really happy to do that stuff but for me
I just don't have it in me it's a skill
I don't have you don't need it actually
I'm pretty good at sales man yeah yeah
that's true well you're also doing it
from a perspective of like it's not a
thing you're selling somebody right I've
been doing it for in for my work yeah
there you go yeah and the person may
only have enough money to buy one thing
but you know you're trying to make them
buy two things when really they don't
even go on Credit Karma they don't know
their credit score they just have like
it's much money they could have a lot
more money if they went to Credit Karma
though oh my god which reminds me to
check out Credit Karma
yeah texted Julian 289 eight hundred for
the free app free credit score checking
monitoring alerts trust me it is a great
way to check to take care of your credit
imagine imagine it as being your first
child really I'm a child it always stays
with you check your credit with credit
karma also check out cams pop to be in
the running to get those posters
actually beautiful canvas pieces of art
not posters follow canvas pop on Twitter
and we must love to win or sign those
and send them to you otherwise
40% off site-wide on campus pop by using
the product coach JJ 40 thank you to our
sponsors I feel like I feel like canvas
pop you could troll people pretty good
let's have a giant picture themselves
something or them oh my god boy were
sent off for Christmas for yet a really
unflattering picture of someone that you
love blow it up and give it to that
person great rolling opportunity there
doesn't come along it's really an
opportunity that's good and then but
don't even give it to them wrapped just
hanging in the house on Christmas I've
just been in their bathroom or something
Jenna I saw a picture on Reddit of
someone with their family and there's
just a picture of their family all
sitting in the living room and it was
like I exchanged the picture of my
sister in the house for Vladimir Putin
and so they were like oh you should put
Stalin underneath them there you go so
yeah the opportunity totally blows
do that you blow up a blow of a picture
of your favorite world leader and this
hanging wrong
gotta catch'em all get thanks for the
debbie machines Thank You Rosa
oh speaking of which Thank You Debbie so
much for joining us it was a pleasure so
much hope it was entertaining otherwise
they love you yeah yeah if you're the
coolest G oh it's week o 2016 the Debbie
machines Debbie's go drop we're gonna
link her Twitter below so you can follow
her for Twitter time at four in the
morning
awesome time on Twitter seriously one of
the best Barlow's I have right now so ah
yeah well lincoin thanks so much adieu
mommy love you mom yeah alright this is
hugging kissing I'll see you guys next
week on the China Julian podcast thanks
Ross